[Music]
you drive a very unusual car what car do
you drive
it's been a dream of mine to always
drive a police interceptor so I bought
this a cop car a retired detective car
on ebay for six grand and it's blacked
out has a side light has a CB radio I
feel you know this the feeling when you
you're you you feel like a cops behind
you and you get that anxiety yeah I love
giving that feeling so I live in Venice
and there's a lot of these side streets
where the kids they'll be standing there
and they'll be like they see you come
you know they're doing it so I'll just
pull there and it's all blacked out and
it's just funny the feeling you get to
give people because I have it
so you're I can drive fast you're
scaring the [ __ ] out of kids in this cop
car what you're basically doing then you
roll down the window and they see that
it's do you ever roll down the window
and then let them see that it's you like
oh I have my shade this is their picture
I think we have a picture of you yeah
there you are I've my shades my shades
my UFC hat I actually have a Santa
Monica those are air landing lights you
have on the side of your car but it has
the CB radio has a loudspeaker and
obviously I don't impersonate a cop I
just have fun feeling like go the extra
mile and get the uniform you do yeah you
have a police uniform is West first
stripping that's my okay all right
that's your business
all right the Expendables 3 we got
Stallone okay we got Mel Gibson
Schwarzenegger Harrison Ford of all
those guys who when your opinion really
still has it in like the most macho way
you know who's the guy who still I'm
sure you're gonna say they're all
terrific but which is the one that in a
fight would win Terry Crews for sure
that caused massive yeah but sly and
Arnold they're they're still ripped I
mean they're they're massive guys and
they watching them fight even well even
Gibson Gibson and sly have a big fight
and they go toe-to-toe and I remember I
saw pictures of Gibson getting it all
the way I mean he look he looks at the
biggest I've ever seen him and then sly
he looked the biggest I ever saw him I
felt like there was a friendly
competition between the two that wasn't
spoken but you could just tell that they
were
they were getting ready what's that you
get does he give workout advice alone
I'm just like his whole life has been a
yeah you know yeah yeah yeah he when I
was on set he told me he has this
workout bar which is like an eight pound
just piece of metal that he'll just work
his forearms with if you think about it
your forearms are the only thing you
really see so getting that all veiny you
look kind of buff anyways but with slide
no one sees my forearm no one has seen
my fool if I don't have one but and then
I'm saying it's cause your forearms what
are you talking about I don't know the
forearm doesn't feel like the muscle to
work out you know there's nothing there
it's just some freckles that's your left
one I bet your left ones what do you
mean there's nothing there there's just
a this is a dermatologist fantasy right
here there's no but I'm saying that
doesn't feel like the thing to work out
I mean it's it's a muscle so that was
his advice so this is why this advice
for the movies will work out your
silhouette so the stuff when you're
wearing clothes your traps your back
your chest you know thighs just your
silhouette muscle so when the lights
behind you you look massive right I
could work out my legs you've seen me in
the gym there's he's seen me in the gym
there's nothing I can do to my legs to
put muscle on them bottom I could no no
no he wants about me no I no matter what
I do other end of the gym and I act like
I don't know him
it's the singing and the dancing I
thought you liked that well k we have an
exclusive sneak peek of the Expendables
3 no one has seen this before nope so
we're going to show this right now this
is our first look at it let's take a
look at this clip from the Expendables 3
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and looking good they're looking really
good they're all expendable
yeah